in ideal world I wouldn't have to talk I
[Music]
don't know I feel like my words are
insults to my thoughts you know that
feeling of not being able to put words
on a dream you've had well that's how I
feel all the time so I wish I could stop
speaking but it's a vortex because even
saying that I don't want to talk forces
me to talk that's why I spend my days
alone with my objects making music my
way no talking just sounds you started
talking because you had something to say
right yeah but like most humans do I
keep talking even when I have nothing to
say and I end up saying useless [ __ ]
think about it most of the words we say
could just never be said and the world
would be just fine
[Music]
but we keep on dropping useless comments
all the time I wish that everything I
said would be so beautiful and so
meaningful that it would be worth being
the title of my new songs but it's
definitely not I wish I could mute
myself and if I really need to say
something or I could just sing it with a
melody and nobody would find it weird or
awkward and if they do some guy said
something like Sammy's what appears when
you scrub the side lands and I like
skirting it with my objects makes me
forget the world focus on the loo that
way life becomes this gigantic
but everyone carries in children in
which every sound is welcome and
enriched the lyrics are nothing but the
Judas worst I would say it's a song that
started before I was born and will
continue
after I disappear but while I'm here and
capturing it to testify of my journey on
earth it's just a never ending song
when you play that never ends